[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas non plus un truc obligatoire
la galoche je tourne d'abord 7 fois la
langue dans ma propre bouche déjà et je
réfléchis comment alors comment c'était
là vraiment j'ai adoré
il a envie de recommencer est-ce que tu
es
à disposition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
avec le prochain coup non
vous allez me prendre un tic tac chacun
et vous allez mettre la langue
attention attention je vais te destituer
Delphine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars
j'ai pris une grande décision
j'espère je ne dors pas avec Béatrice
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez recommencer après et si
vous embrassez gilet Guillaume se rend
embrasseront avec plaisir et après
Jean-Marie fera ce qu'il vous
bien entendu
Mathieu a dit
avec moi
quand je parte permis de conduire c'est
sur une Ferrari
c'est un truc de fou cette émission
anaïssa
nexami à moi enfin tout ce qui
expliquerait quoi tomber de pas que ça
euh Mathieu comment c'était très
agréable est-ce que tu pourrais sentir
du Rubicon alors avec Delphine ou
Delphine
vraiment si c'est vraiment alors
peut-être pas filmer là mais mais est-ce
que tu pourrais franchir la barrière du
Rubicon alors il a les lèvres très
douces et pas que les lèvres
on m'a parlé lui on l'appelle au but
non mais j'ai pas fait de rencontre la
dernière fois que j'ai fait l'amour avec
une femme j'avais c'était il y a ouais
il y a 20 ans
et quand il vous
tient et ça ça fait vraiment du bien
alors Mathieu Mathieu Mathieu est-ce que
tu serais prêt à vivre une nouvelle
expérience avec Delphine
alors c'est bizarre comme question tu me
l'as comme ça si je peux commencer
[Applaudissements]